hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the matching of Duda
vs sergeant arigasi from the meltwater
Champions Chester finals we've already
shown the first game of the match and it
was a very nice one if you remember Duda
just sacrificed a night for fun and then
it kind of worked out uh the second game
where Arjun had the white pieces entered
in a draw and now this is game three
where they repeat the line from game one
only as you've seen from the thumbnail
the game takes an uh most unexpected
turn so let's dive straight into it uh
do that with the white pieces opens with
C4 so we have a repetition from game one
upon the C6 the Karo Khan to the English
Knight F3 we have Pawn to D5 G3 and in
game one G6 was played but here we have
D captures and C4 this is sort of an
offbeat line still not the main
continuation Bishop to G2 and now Knight
to F6 we have castles and pawn to B5 so
nicely Defending Your pawns here but of
course the white will challenge that
pawn to A4 now goes after the beef five
Pawn you want to make your light Square
Bishop even more powerful Bishop to B7
and now Pawn to D3
and here Arjun just captured C
characters and D3 I will mention however
that this position has been reached in
the 2015 World rapid championship in a
game between atigo and levonovich
Petrosian and vishwanathan Anand Anand
played B4 in this position and he won
the game I'm just uh you know gonna put
that out there but okay C captures on D3
uh Knight the E5 now now opening up your
light Square Bishop you can also
recapture on D3 with the Knight and the
way Arjun should continue this game is B
captures and A4 and after Knight
captures here just play E6 play
something like Bush p7 castle and uh
well uh get your king to safety as soon
as possible however after dudas Knight
the E5 Arjun played Queen the C8 and uh
his position is now just a lost
incredible as it is uh it's only move
eight but feel free to pause the video
and win this game for Duda while I give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on figuring out
it's the move from the thumbnail but
even bigger congratulations to those of
you who figure out you have to capture
on B5 first so that's the way to do it
congratulations if you've spotted this
if you play Queen to B3 right away you
go after F7 just E6 and nothing is
happening here if you capture on B5 now
then just captures an E2 and uh well but
black is definitely defending here
however after eight captures on B5 there
is really no good way to meet this uh
move so see calculus on B5 was played
and now Queen to B3 we enter the
position from the thumbnail and yes this
is only move 10 and there's a really
nothing black can do the problem is if
you try to defend the F7 Pawn then Queen
captures and B5 with check and you lose
the bishop on B7 and you resign it's
really nothing to do here like Knight B
to D7 you can cap run B7 and okay if
Rook B8 you can just trade Bishop
captures a capture Sun B5 captures and
D7 Knight captures Knight captures on D3
and you're just up a full night so not
gonna happen so after Queen to B3 uh
Arjun said all right I have to go for
Bishop captress on G2 Queen captures on
F7 with check King to d8 and now King
captures on G2 d captures on E2 yeah
black does have some control play going
after the rook and F1 Rook to E1 and now
Knight the C6 and uh you have to decide
how to continue this game of course you
want to develop your knight and Bishop
but if you try something like Bishop to
F4 which seems like a good move it's
very easy for black to just trade off
everything captures captures Queen B7
check and have to remove the king queen
to D5 attacks the bishop attacks the
queen and you have to trade Queens here
after captors captures
real characters on E2 uh it's okay white
is a little bit better but nothing uh
nothing spectacular so instead after
Knight the C6 Duda goes back Knight to
F3 better to keep the tension uh Queen
to B7 now with some very nasty
discoveries in mind if the knights move
but just Rook to A3 by Duda with some
ideas of Rook to D3 check so Knight the
E5 guarding D3 and also putting more
pressure on this F3 pawn and now Queen
to E6 luckily the Rook also guards the
F3 Pawn but now your knight is hanging
and there just isn't a good way for you
to deal with this even if you play B4
and I know you guys are interested in
what happens if B4 then Rook to D3 with
check or even Rook to E3 goes after the
Knight first you have to win the D3
Square then black will have to capture
and then you will again win the D3
Square for your Rook so here uh Arjun
does it right away Rook captures and
Knight captures and F3 Rook captures on
F3 and now Queen to E4 he wants to trade
Queens but now Queen to A6 and there's
really no good way to defend the B5 Pawn
uh whatever you do the B5 Pawn is going
to fall but it's not so much about the
B5 Pawn I want to capture on B5 you
again gain control over the D3 Square uh
and okay for the Moment The Rook can't
move but the queen can't really remain
here forever Knight is coming to to C3
the Queen the queen will be kicked away
so what could you do here could you play
some B4 moves uh here like going after
the
and the C3 Square not really because the
queen from A6 and also one of the
reasons why Queen to A6 is so
Spectacular Now attacks the E2 Pawn so
if you open up this diagonal by playing
B4 to stop Knight to C3 then Rook
captures a knee to end you lose this E2
Pawn without the E2 Pawn there's really
no point in playing this game so another
thing you could do is let's say you play
Queen to C4 uh you could also maybe
maybe try this Defender B5 Pawn this way
then Knights the A3 attacks the queen
and the B5 Pawn so you're gonna win the
B5 Pawn once again and if you play Queen
to A4 then you can just play a rook to
D3 check because you won the D3 Square
now it's a queen to C6 check picks up
the Rook here and uh Arjun can just
resign so it's a very very delicate
position Arjun plays Rook the C8 uh he
he has to try something but now a very
nice Queen captures on B5 and now the D3
square is available to The Rook once the
queen moves from this diagonal Ponte E6
getting ready to develop the dark Square
Bishop but now do the also will take
this moment to develop his dark Square
Bishop so Bishop G5 Bishop to E7 and now
finally Knight the C3 attacks the black
queen queen to C6 still keeping an eye
on this diagonal and now Queen captures
a knee to eliminating this beautiful
past pawn and remarkable as it is uh we
are now in a situation where the
material is completely equal but of
course arjun's King is uh not feeling
very happy they're on d8 we have
knighted the D7 offering a trade of
Bishops because uh well for the moment
D6 Pawn is saying but also your bishop
and G5 is hanging so here Arjun was
hoping for captors captures and then the
king and the queen are guarding the E6
Pawn but after Knight to D7 Duda just
plays Knights the E4 and after Pawn to
H6 just to Rook the C1 as the bishop
also covers the C1 Square so here doodle
wants to trade Queen to A8 with Rook
captures and C8 Queen captures and now
the spectacular Knight to D6 and he was
in this position animal of 26 that Arjun
ergasi resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here uh so
really really spectacular stuff here
from Duda winning both games in this
line Arjun didn't really find a way how
to deal with all all the mess Duda can
create uh here we resign because the
queen is hanging the bishop of course
cannot capture because it's pinned and
once you move the queen you can just
trade Knight to F7 check Forks the king
and the rook and once you move the king
even Bishop captures on E7 his instant
resigns from black uh you can't do
anything if you capture the bishop you
lose the Rook you you don't really have
a good Square for The Rook if you move
the Rook to G then we just move the
bishop we just wanna three piece on E7
so however you play this uh White will
just be up too much material and there's
no point in continuing this uh but yeah
very nicely done by Duda game he wins
both of his games with white pieces both
of his games with a draw piece with the
black pieces ended in a draw so he wins
the match against Arjun irrigation three
to one a very nice start for Duda and
I've received a a message or maybe
someone sent it in the comments I don't
really remember that saying that I don't
pronounce it properly it's not young
Duda so if that is truly the case uh you
know uh send me like a confirmation on
an email or something like that like the
best thing for you to do if you want to
improve my pronunciation of um a certain
players names is to just send me an
email with the actual audio so I can I
can hear how you pronounce it if you're
a native speaker but yeah I I believe
it's not young
so if that is the case I don't mind
pronouncing it uh properly just you know
give me like yeah that's that that's
pretty good uh but yeah that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it very nicely
done by Yang shisht of Duda truly truly
spectacular chess being played here I
mean uh how do you how do you even uh
imagine a position like this being on
the board on move 10 like like this is
move 10 I mean absolutely absolutely
spectacular uh so yeah and once again
really hope you guys enjoyed it I would
like to thank Jonathan Bradley
Christopher Norris Microsoft and Mikhail
arboy and Fernando Gibson for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon and continuing the coverage of
the meltwater Champions Chester finals
until it finishes so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day